uh yeah hi so
I'm going to talk to you about some work
joint with me
which is uh titled batch proof of
statistical hiding which is perhaps the
main message to take away from what I'm
going to say and there are a couple of
different ways of uh viewing what I'm
going to tell you on the perspective I'm
going to take today is that we provide
answers to this question the question of
when can you batch proofs
so let me start by defining my terms
because I'm going to use them in a
slightly different way from okay for
batch proof to me
for an MP language l looks like this you
have approval and verifier and you have
t instances both of the models the
program knows Witnesses for these
instances if there is instances and the
talk and approval is trying to prove to
the verifier that all of the instances
are in the language
and the essential properties available
are has to be complete and everything is
going to be perfectly complete don't
think about that
uh I want both these parties to be
polynomial time the proverb polynomials
I want the blue system to be succinct
meaning that the total communication in
the entire system is
much less than P let's say t to the one
minus Epsilon function constant Epsilon
uh and the system is statistically small
this is about proof uh and if it helps
you can think of this t as being
significantly larger than the instances
in the businesses so so technical issues
don't come up okay
very basic primitive a very basic
complexity theoretic object you have
T instances T fitnesses can I prove to
you that all of them are in the language
without having to communicate all my
weaknesses to you
and uh I'm going to ask a very
fundamental question about this
fundamental parameter which is which
languages in NP can have these groups
or surprisingly we do not have that many
good answers to this question we know
is
you know I I have a better job than this
but this is not the audience
uh yeah so we know this and you can
probably get these for some specific
structured languages
I don't know any simple languages I have
this property but I can tell you more
about this later if you're interested
and this is basically everything we know
and so yeah the world sort of looks like
this you have you can do it for pup and
some other languages here and there we
don't know anything else
and what I want to ask is what can what
else can you get this for in particular
can I get it for all of them
and how many people think we should be
able to get this first
um
thank you so what if you don't do UT you
do something like up you have a unique
answer what happens if you have a small
number of options you can do things
where does it stop you can use Twitter
stuff
so what's the answer to my question
[Music]
one of the things that you're able to
say is
we'll make you some so for the record I
think you should not be able to do this
what we give is some sort of
some
justification for why you should know at
least some way to bolster my position on
this question
be sure that if a language has bad foods
then it has a certain kind of
statistically witnessing machine
okay let me again Define all the story
on the same page whatever
synthesizability well so you have uh
pick any instance in the language and
two different images as well and imagine
running a proof system you have with
both these instances both these
weaknesses and what we want is that
these executions look the same to the
effect even if the verifier is trying to
actively figure out which weakness you
used
uh yeah for for any malicious but if I
really can't tell statistical you cannot
that the views on the verifier and the
two executions are statistic interests
right and to this for some error
and yeah honestly is doing the same
thing only problems
one thing to point out is that if we
have Innovation improve as a studio so
this is a thing that only really really
is
so let me with this let me tell you more
precisely about
languages
then you have a honestly reference with
a couple of caveats it has this profiles
are not ready for improver and it's uh
error with this Industries
as opposed to exponentials
and uh
and I want to say that if you think of
this as a construction if you think
there is a way of constructing these
proofs then these are perhaps things of
concerning but I but if if the first
part you're taking is what I want to
take here and think of these as
indications of whether this looks exists
or not and I want to suggest that these
differences are not these caveats are
not
what is the difference
on the success
[Music]
foreign
uh well if the if you're only
communicating a very small number of its
constant number of bits below the one
with us so yeah because yeah yeah
one witness at least you can certainly
see that some exponential thing happens
no no uh there is like a complexity
you can uh you can get that groups for
NP with a b space
yes anything you I mean so it's a little
this is one way
showing application yeah let me repeat
that just to just point it out that if I
did not have the Restriction of the
pillar being efficient then you can get
this problem anything simply because I
have equals
efficient tools
I guess I expected preserve rounds
uh yes
does the non-uniform advice depend on
the X the statement you're proving no
then it's true okay
so this is interesting even if there's
just two witnesses right so you that
says that you don't expect questions
this is interesting even if there's just
two witnesses right so that you don't
expect badge proves even for two
businesses right
if you uh
if you believe we don't have Windows yes
sorry right because they were requiring
t to the one minus Epsilon they were
requiring not even one bit for each of
the instances
controllers I'm
um
why do we not expect statistical level
you want
just because we don't know
what is the reason is there any reason
beyond the fact that we have no idea how
to do it I get done okay answers I don't
have a good reason but
so like statistical zero knowledge you
don't expect unconditionally yeah
but think of a language like some
disgusting language
yeah efficiently
the same kind of uh sounds really weird
yeah that just basically my reason for
feeling that they should not exist but
then you know more surprising things
have happened in your lifetime
we don't expect like swi the cause under
complement I guess yeah because
yeah it contains two people
I'll say a bit more about this stuff in
a minute but uh let me just finish up
here by saying that if you really can
you can actually make these malicious
verifiers in certain cases
but
okay maybe if you you may care about
this if uh if you care about it as a
construction but I want to set up on my
buttons
thank you
are there uh
you need some assumptions
but
so it's a nurse and in other words you
know if you believe that your language
does not have these rules then it does
no no no no to answer the question they
were asking earlier they can ask this
question
and Which languages
certainly appearance
right and perhaps this is a sort of
transformation for why up was the class
for which we first formed which is
uh and uh
what's the soundness of the swi crew
statistics
the normal sort of negligible uh yeah
that's it
all right you can also show that
languages in this class
because physical knowledge tools the
only remaining question is do you have
an efficient for this things like we
know what you do some very interesting
work with these languages do have zero
knowledge proofs at the Patients
um
and these classes in this languages in
this class are maybe an example for
languages that are not in ut that have
Solutions
uh you can take some combinations of
these languages kind of language from
here language
I know you can ask
so how many people think that Circle has
yes
I don't think it's like a thing we
should be scared of I'm on the offense
the best in the beginning how many
people believe that there is swi
will increase
so two and a half
and uh
and now this is the number of people who
believe that NP has bad news
so I have already delivered something
and also this is
like yeah
yeah so these are all good questions
towards answering this question that guy
was saying earlier you don't expect to
have educations because technology is
so
it's um I believe in this is not as
strong as it's not like
yeah this is this is how much we know
so I was saying my faith that MP does
not have these groups is clear you're
not as strong as my friends they don't
be interested
because it doesn't have catastrophic at
least so far as frequently it does not
have
difficult so that's that's a very
interesting question to try to answer
would there'll be better for the
consequences
are there implications from witness
hiding
uh not so Windows hiding is sort of a
computational notion so you wouldn't
really play a Rolex
does the picture change if you just ask
about non-attractive swi
um
in in these suspects
maybe I don't know I don't know how I
don't have any composition thing to say
about that but I'll see a little bit
later okay so all this for proofs
so maybe you don't have proofs for
anything right but what we know we do
have is arguments
foreign
and we've known for a long time that you
can use functions to get even constants
now something even a constant round
successful arguments
and recently people noticed that you can
actually improve this to something
slightly bigger seemingly which are
these multiplication
uh and these seem to be the make us
assumptions may not contribute
and the question I want to ask here is
what assumptions are necessary what
really is the vehicle what is the real
complexity of this problem
um and over here also we can say
something we can draw some similar
conclusions okay it's the same approach
you can start you can show that if you
have batch Arguments for all FNP this is
not language specific this time you have
it for all of NP then you end up with uh
these uh similar HP arguments
and this is also wrong preserving here
we care about it a bit more because
constant loans and it has the same
careers
and further with uh if you assume a
little bit more if you're using one-way
functions then you can use some somewhat
standard transformations to actually get
ezekic arguments
friends
with about the same number of times it's
the same caveats but over the same
number of numbers
and
[Music]
uh
so in a sense this sort of ties together
the complexity of batch arguments in
this department it's like whatever you
believe about what do you believe in
Need for sick arguments
yeah
you have
um
that you don't really that this line of
inference is
that's what tell you something is
so interpreting that foreign
right so whatever you believe about this
now we also believe this
yes this is the answer I promised the
other day
thanks to the question
maybe it was what was the question about
uh just it wasn't about lecturing it's a
very safe
oh you're saying it's a succinct or even
for NP yeah it's even stronger yeah
[Music]
foreign
too much
that comes from somewhere and typically
you ask for a doctor's office
and now you can show something again we
know a number of transactions know from
uh from specific assembly right and
again also I want to ask the same
question what assumptions are actually
necessary
and making sure something very similar
right where you can take a much
argument same value and you can also
show that
negot
so that's all I want to say about this
unless someone else so these are all the
results that I want to tell you I'm
going to move on
any questions
so in the interactive setting like the
two side table uh
yeah
yeah but there's one thing we don't know
how to do oh I mean why it doesn't
matter
the uh oh yeah sorry
about loss APK because don't we have
non-injected batch arguments from like
like heuristically from Ash functions
that things that don't look like
it seems surprising that uh
so I haven't told you what zombies are
foreign
[Music]
fit yeah yeah
I don't know
yeah it's like a distribution yes that's
a good way to think
but you have these different businesses
comes from any of them you are able to
sample the same distributions
is
okay so the next one I'll tell you
just
discussion is
difficult but we know about this yeah
something even stronger yeah can you can
you yeah can we do that for example I
give you site formula I give you one
side of things
very much
yeah
[Music]
or even let's say
something that is not directly in the
line of implications but what if I give
you with a random business
es
but more questions
no no this doesn't make sense something
in which trivia thing of planting
doesn't work yeah
okay so let me tell you how we do this
and let's uh I'm going to show all this
show you what we do in the simplest case
there is some proof Computing function f
a diploma uses to compute the proof like
sends the proof over and the guarantee
you have is at the very fair accepts
this blue people only if all the
instances of language
and yeah everyone installing all my time
are using the non-interactive setting
now
are you
uh yeah so take the simplest
possibilities right everyone has become
interested everyone is
right and this is what the blue system
looks like and and I also tell you the
size of the proof is less than much less
than
right so the spelling can you show that
this language
is uh it's very close to this uh this
this this approach that is industrous
but quite simple and natural but but
very very clever approach taken by
Andrew Drucker in the context of incense
compression and if you have time I'll
tell you about this at 10 or not it's
very cool
uh yeah so we want this and what are
they going to do
now what should we do so I have this
right I want to come up with a SMB blue
foreign so in in that proof I'm going to
be given one instance and one witness
how am I going to use
any other ideas
pick others
that's sort of what I'm going to do so
and the the nutrition underlying
everything I'm going to avoid the fact
that this proof is shaking right so and
in particular it has fewer bits than the
number of weaknesses that the people was
given so it cannot possibly remember all
of the witnesses
now what I'm hoping to do is to take the
witness I am given for the one specific
instance and put it somewhere and hope
that the proof Pi forgets about it
this is what if I do uh so this is our
root I am going to given this x and the
proof over as a w the blue is somehow
going to pick a number of other
instances in the language you have to
figure out how to do that it's going to
do that and if you want to pick a random
location among the three locations put
the specific instance with the spell
there and whatever it is sampled over
here everywhere else
I was going to compute the proof that
comes out of this
I'm going to send over to the verifier
this proof and also all the instances
that it came up with
f is the function that computes the
proof
in the batch MD
so sorry to do this
is also says quite simple it runs the
batch verifier with this instance so it
takes all the exercises we're going to
put it appropriately it's going to
insert the X in the jth position
I'm just going to use the batch proof
file I'm going to see whether it will
fix
just convinces us that there is a
statistical WI
I thank you
Literature Like have one particular
witness that is like completely
remembered and the proverb can't find
out what it is yeah so this is the
challenge so I always clear that the
system was completely consumed that part
is fine but why is it wi uh I remember
show you that there is some way in which
you can pick these xiwl that makes it a
solution okay it's not it's not
obviously
uh
yeah so you know this is
and the big question is is definitely
measurement so let's take the simplest
case okay let's say that there is some
one instance and two of its witnesses
that be careful forget about everything
else
I only want my proof system to be
witnessed industratable for this
instance and these two witnesses
and now is that a way to pick the excise
and WIS so that this happens so the blue
system is witnessed an institution will
follow this instance in these businesses
sampling
noise in the first place
yeah it's going to come uniform address
but you're saying that that
the proof system may be geared toward
this particular instance
it looks looks for x if x is there yeah
that's what I'm really worried about and
that's the kind of thing that could
that's perhaps the simplest adversary
that could break into
which is where it looks for one specific
instances if it finds that it just
outputs the w
right because the output length of this
F is smaller than T but it's still
larger than one which cancel out to the
fields right that's what I'm going to do
and now I want to say that if you only
care about bitterness discrimination but
before one specific instance and two
specific processors then there is a way
to avoid this specific attack
the F that looks for this X and outputs
the witness partner comes with it what
is that how do you do that
oh
yeah yeah so that's what I'm going to do
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
pick all of my X I's to be the same X
and each of my w eyes I'm going to pick
at random from the two instances that I
can
so the attacker that looks for the X and
outputs the weakness that comes with it
now has no idea which business I use
because all the instances are X and I've
used both businesses
if there's a polynomial advantage
all right so this is simple and how am I
going to prove that this is fine so but
is for this particular attacker this
particular adversarial if this works you
can have more generalists and it turns
out you can actually show that this is
good enough for any other cylinder and
the way you know this is using this uh
it's very clean and simple Lemma about
compressing functions from Tucker and
simplified trans
which is so this is this okay take any
function
G that is shrinking by even some
constant Factor
and look at the following two
distributions so the first distribution
is I pick a random jig and
that J I think should be zero all the
other inputs are random
and the other distribution is again I
pick a random J and that particular jth
entry f x b one and everything else is
done
so these are two distributions
an old you can show using some
Elementary information Theory arguments
is that these two are statistical rules
and what this is is
what this is it's a statement about
essentially the noise sensitivity of
shrinking functions
I'm saying that if you have a function
that shrinks then it cannot really
depend that heavily on every single bit
it probably doesn't depend that much on
some of the bits even something similar
to tell in your paper
yeah like 1998 formulation
[Music]
I know
because this game these are like 10
years ago
right fine fine this dependence is also
tight this one's quite a bit and that's
I'll leave that as homework foreign
uh and you said every X and to be NX
70wa could be a random one of these you
pick the random location and you put the
vectors you care about in the location
and and the other things in other places
and we got this too right we put w0 X Y
zero
and
all you have to do is apply the Lemma I
just showed you with this function G
with the function that takes is input
bits and uses the bits to select which
Witness Goes back
and it turns out you can actually extend
this quite easily to distributions as
well like so far I fixed one instance
but let's say you had some distribution
over an instance in terms of witnesses
that you want to be contemplary
on the car only about Fitness consisting
machine for instance Witnesses drawn
from this distribution
and you can do exactly the same thing
like this is
and you do exactly the same thing you
sample all the excise and WIS also from
the distribution
and again this will fold the
the adversarial function it won't know
which is the actual instance and which
will actually also which once was a
sample from the same distribution
uh
wait but this recursive no no what I
mean there can be
it's not the same X every time different
X's here yeah
so why can't the compression function
remember One X and one weakness that is
the X and the witness
like
this is a hypothetic statement over the
random X it won't work for everyone this
is a statement only in expectation it
does not work over the place
first like the trooper to know both WC
or something you want right uh if the
quest approved to be able to sample from
this distribution
yeah
yeah yes so the proofer doesn't normally
approve it just gets like a single X and
W and has to prove like you can sample
from the distribution that's fine but
that's not what it is
doing is follow the instance of business
it's given it is putting it down
is
oh these are different yeah
so good oh sorry so you're still
sampling X from D we are not preparing D
after CS no
yeah the auto new things happen to
someone in the sky samples this and
gives me just one of the two I'm a group
someone is sampling this you will meet
one of the two witnesses I am sampling
these
these things and I am I am something
these I am doing this and computers
uh so for the specific instance that you
care about you know business but for the
others
you need to have two weaknesses you just
need to have something with the
distribution of the weakness within the
instances yeah
it's a simpler
10 minutes
and this is this kind of distributional
notion of meters and distribution right
because you only have the guarantee in
expectation over this distribution this
specific distributions but the nice
thing is you have this for every
distribution in particular
you have a proof system
that or rather for every distribution
over the x w one there is some
distribution from which you can sample
the excess interviews for which the
proof system is wa for that distribution
right so this we have this kind of
distribution lwi
what is really want however is you want
actual NWA you want something that works
for every instance
right in particular you want a way to
sample the excise and WS that is
separate from the ideal separate from
the X but you want that to be one way to
pick all that system WS that works for
every possible instance in passive
indices
so what am I going to do
first
and Max and Max
volume and Max and uh no I'm not going
to go into details because I don't have
much time but left as homework you can
do index and I still want to be able to
sample this doesn't give you some
probability but you can do
in sparse versions of the max which is
why the non-uniformity comes from
because the what you really do is you
take many many samples from this and
then you sample from the empirical
distribution
uh and uh yeah this is this is the this
is anti-proof
it's not that hard to film the details
you can handle more rounds uh any
questions
sorry whatever is the compression Lemma
error yeah
uh yeah again how many more rounds by
just flattening the protocol because
when you're talking about wi you only
care about the honest so you can imagine
a very fair actually since it's well
from that
uh
you know and uh yeah this is all the
technical stuff I want to tell you and I
have a bunch of questions that come out
of this
a lot of things
starting with this the question is can
you actually get
it but he want to answer that
generally you know there are lots of
properties
which is again in contrast to this class
as a cable which we know a lot of things
okay and really the big difference in
our ability to analyze this classes is
that SDK has this efficiency levels
it seems to make it quite different but
I'd like to understand there's a close
number of different operations
another really interesting
question is whether you can
Construction
company came from this has been Max can
we make it in the form
you could try applying the uniform in
Max theorems that we know but those have
the our games don't have the properties
you need for them
and also another property I don't know
what SWA is whether you can amplify the
if you start with inverse polynomial
independent question
other questions can you show
stronger bonus for let's say
non-intracted batch groups right which
should be even less powerful and in
particular the bad shoes we know for up
are Interactive
they take uh I think they work for any
quantum number of phones on the the
trade-off in the communication is such
that if you try to do this kind of uh
your Zone direction for this interactive
rules you end up with something trivial
if you try to make them more
intellective or even like to message
sorry
is that inherent you said that
non-attractive batch moves are
significantly weaker than
significantly stronger than natural
that's true and more limited and in that
case it's not even clear that unbounded
tours can do much even for a constant
number of rounds actually the ibps
connection still requires a polynomial
number of rooms so constants known
that's true so you can still ask even if
with unborn what can I do not clear
languages
do you guys have any other questions or
not
so I think it's super interesting to get
batch proofs for NP where the
communication can grow say linearly with
the number of instances that you're not
sending the tea witness you're sending
in one witness plus T times something
yeah so I think this approach might work
for for a small extent maybe till the T
login bits or something but beyond that
um
it only makes sense for languages in NP
or because
I don't know any other Beyond MP I don't
know because I don't know
when would swi live like
[Music]
understand
I think you can still do it by yourself
[Music]
thank you
guys
what's up
so up to now we will be talking about
the computational assumptions
tell us a bit about physical assumptions
and how they interact with consultation
with complexity assumptions
yes thank you hi
um